what's that sweetheart
you're not smart
i don't think you're smart i don't think
you're smart
if you were smart you would know that's
what's funny about the joke
that's the exact thing that's funny
about the joke
but i think your math brain isn't
creative enough to understand humor
no no i'm being serious no no i'm being
i don't think your brain is made for
humor
like you're probably really good at
other things but your brain i don't
think is made for it i'll give you a
chance for the rest of the show to try
to laugh
but if you find yourself not laughing
just know i'm not smart enough that's
what you have to remind me
your brain doesn't work for it it's not
everybody
i'm sure you're really good at
engineering no you're really good at
engineering
ruining other people's
um nights selfish you got all those down
but humor is not for you
that's fair and look there is a place to
go if you don't like humor
is no you shouldn't go to hell
why would you go to hell that's for
funny people
you're not gonna ruin our time in hell
too
how dare you [ __ ] you don't follow me
to [ __ ] hell [ __ ]
i'm not your [ __ ] mind i gotta deal
with you here and in [ __ ] hell
do you think you can behave for one
story no you can't
really do i have to kick you guys out
that would suck
it's your birthday i don't give a [ __ ]
i really don't it's not
that's such a childish [ __ ] thing to
say
it's my birthday i can interrupt your
entire show
can you imagine if someone just like
crashed into your car and you're like
dude he's like it's my birthday
so i i'm
i'm allowed to behave like an idiot
you're like okay but that doesn't
excuse your behavior
it's your birthday i know he's going
with what i was saying i mean it's the
same volley it's my birthday
you know what i heard actually is that
on 9 11 it was osama bin laden's
birthday
so i i forgive him i think it's totally
cool
yes i compared this table of four women
to isis and i don't
i don't feel bad about it
[Music]
what your boobs are really thank you
maybe tell me that later instead of
during a performance
so you're not you're not welcome to
speak i'm trying to make that really
clear
to
everybody at the same time it is not
appropriate to yell [ __ ] at me
right now
it is less appropriate to yell at me
than almost
anybody within several square miles
if you yell at a guy on the street
you're not
ruining a show for 2500
[ __ ] people so it's literally
one of the few me and the
pilot you shouldn't talk to those are
the only people
a pilot flying a plane at that moment
and me doing this in a ballerina the
three of us
leave us the [ __ ] alone so that we can
give you what you paid for
for you not for me i don't care i can't
be hurt
i can't be 45 years old
i have used up every kind of crime
and it's all i've used them all
it's like you can't jerk off to the same
picture more than like three or four
times then it just becomes nothing like
a blank piece of paper
that's how all my feelings are now
that's how all my emotions and impulses
are yeah and i know about that that's
fine i've done that
no reaction female central energy
beautiful and sublime even in
masturbation
even when they're masturbating like the
rap man of concerto played across the
clitoris
[Music]
female sexuality
is there is alcohol it's invaded your
consciousness and the alcohol is telling
you that you have things that are worth
saying the alcohol is lying to you now
[Applause]
later after the show if your face is not
as ugly as your voice
we will occupy that gaping orifice in
your head
not with my [ __ ] though something
dipped in herpes we will drape across
your face
and seal it shut with leprosy and stabs
please not be busy by a holy disease
i'm done okay sorry just talking about
nine thousand dollars to [ __ ] fly
here
no offense but there's no eiffel tower
here i think that's a little pricey
thank you you're welcome thank you for
not just laughing
thank you for verbally letting me know
that you appreciated that
thank you
she has no stairs in her in her house or
someone doesn't know how to walk up them
did you call did you call the planner
thank you
[Applause]
is
[Music]
that's how i heard it
[Music]
if i could say one thing about the real
heroes of the
uh country which i believe are the
teachers you know
um i don't really i don't believe it
just spoke again
i actually i think the real heroes are
the real hero
it's counterintuitive that it doesn't
seem like a heroic job
but yes
first of all if you're a teacher you get
the same kind of vacations as a child
like four months a year
my vacation i get almost no time out
there we're 48 weeks a year
like four weeks a year i get up what
about you
now i was [ __ ] teachers right
[Music]
great
that's a easy one that's the other way
around
it's always easy to ask the
the real questions are other [ __ ]
students
so you need a grade 13 education
here
here